obviously we've got a Bitcoin just
absolutely going sideways uh between a
pretty big range over the last uh few
weeks but we're coming up on a 10th red
weekly candle explain to people the
significance of uh these red candles on
the weekly uh charts
yeah I mean I I just think it's kind of
a fun fact that we've reached a record
number of downed candles and everyone
keeps saying well you know we've got the
eighth in a row certainly next week will
be green we've got the ninth in a row
certainly next week will be green and
here we are at this nasty wick on the
top side of the candle and looks like
we're currently at least as we're
speaking
um in the 10th red week in a row so
pretty pretty brutal price action and
over the last few months
all right and then if you start to look
at the importance of this is it just
something that Traders look at or should
like regular Bitcoin holders who are
just dollar cost averaging in or just
hold Bitcoin to protect their economic
value should they care about this idea
of like a 10-week losing streak like
what's the significance of 10 weekly red
candles
I mean I just think it goes to show you
like how unprecedented the current price
action has been relative to bitcoin's
history uh and as we'll get to in a
moment you know I think this is a great
time to DCA into Bitcoin
um we'll talk in a moment that you know
we haven't reached full reset on a lot
of these on-chain oscillators as well as
reach some of these uh technical levels
things like the mayor multiple or the
200-week moving average but we are you
know very close to those and in the
lower 10th or 25th percentile of all
these unchain metrics I mean which we've
been saying for the last month or two
but it still holds true I think for
people who dollar cost average into this
asset this is the time where you want to
be ramping up your DCA and as I kind of
put on Twitter a little while ago I
think this is a DCA or Paradise uh and I
think you know relative to bitcoin's
history uh where Bitcoins trading based
off of just price action oriented things
or also behavioral things shown by
on-chain I think we're at great kind of
area to average into for the long-term
investor for sure
all right and then if we go ahead and we
take a look at uh these lower time
frames uh and Bitcoin kind of being
ranged bound you've got a chart here uh
that's showing us
um what looks like is just trading
within this band what what exactly are
you pulling from uh from this one
yeah I really honestly just put this
chart in here just to show like how
horrendous this price action has been
over the last like two or three weeks
we've just been in a range and it just
is grabbing liquidity on both sides of
it so meaning like you know you fake out
to the upside of the range fake out
below the bottom of the range it's just
not the type of trading that I find
conducive in this environment I think
you know in this environment you want to
be building long-term positions and
things that you're convicted and
obviously for me that's that's Bitcoin
uh but yeah really just you know maybe
if you have some type of you know real
material Edge and Order flow or
something like that on these slower time
frames then that's different uh but you
know I think even for people that are
just looking to play the range that even
really hasn't been that conducive
because you've just seen price action
faking out to both sides and trapping
Traders looking to trade the break out
of the range on both sides so just
pretty horrendous ugly choppy price
action hey you if you like this video
great we make film a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you're
subscribe like the video and see you
next time